[Musique]
meeting plateau téléconférence depuis
qui a examiné plus sur ces news son nom
est partout d'ailleurs eric zemmour eric
zemmour eric cazes et monde eric zemmour
est pourtant toujours aucune candidature
officielle à la présidentielle alors
business médiatique au projet politique
tout le monde commence à se demander à
quoi joue véritablement eric zemmour
écoutez moi j'ai l'impression que je
suis toujours le même c'est une enquête
parue dans libération qui révèle le
business juteux de zemmour et son
rapport à l'argent accommoder avec la
sortie de son livre la france n'a pas
dit son dernier mot il a explosé les
compteurs avec près de 200000
exemplaires vendus il aurait empoché la
modique somme de 1,5 million d'euros
c'est totalement totalement
exceptionnel sans compter tous les
soutiens financiers qu'il obtient depuis
que l'homme est crédité à 17 % dans les
sondages et donc pour certains
atteignent des 7500 euros selon
libération encore eric zemmour empoché
plus de 50000 euros par mois avec ses
salaires de chroniqueurs sont senio des
paris première ou d'éditorialistes au
figaro alors êtes vous choqué par le
business autour d'eric zemmour
c'est vrai que le business est
incroyable business d'eric zemmour
florian tu as des chiffres c'est un
grand homme je lisais aussi mais c'est
vrai que c'est fou alors sur ses nous
lorsqu'il était chroniqueur il aurait
touché entre 2000 et 3000 euros bruts
par croire chronique c'est ça oui
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est très
confortable d'être dans la vo lu tion
d'eric zemmour à ce stade particulier ne
veut continuer le cas échéant à
monétiser ses services et à faire de
l'argent avec sa présence ses prises de
parole une fois qu'il sera
officiellement candidat ce sera beaucoup
plus compliqué pour lui voire impossible
de continuer à faire financer ces prises
de mélissa faisait maintenant je suis
désolé mais tu es bien c'est une news
comme interviewer il est passé sur
l'iphone non mais alors on a on a les
chiffres sur ces nouvelles quand il est
interviewé sur sur une autre chaîne
j'allais dire france a terminé par mais
s'il va vous croyez quand il va les
missions de faire casser la gueule ils
vendent les bénévoles ils ont des livres
derrière le livre c'est aussi
passionnant avait
dirigé vrai qu'il est rémunéré pour 1
100 chambres et qu'on donne les chiffres
lorsqu'il était chroniqueur elle aurait
touché entre 2000 et 3000 euros brut
soit environ 40000 euros brut par mois
sur ses nous parler première 14000 euros
net par mois le figaro 8000 euros brut
et son livre carton deux cent mille
exemplaires avec les pré commandes
désormais dieter et touchera 8 à 10
euros nets par livre c'est à dire entre
un million six cent mille euros et 2
millions son ancien best-seller le
suicide français il a touché 2,7
millions d'euros en tout pour ce livre
gilles c'est césar oui sur le livre il
est ce qu'on appelle en auto publication
il avait rompu avec son éditeur il s'est
auto publié donc ça veut dire qu'il est
selon mes informations à 50% le livre 21
euros 90 quand il en vend 1 il touche la
moitié de 21 euros 4 mais c'est mal il
est annoncé en train de donner le
chiffre non mais vous êtes choqués vous
ça vous choque moi la raison mais ben
oui oui pas la reine sait tout mieux que
l'arrêt des deux millions d'euros mais
sa voix chaude profile à droite est
choqué isabelle fonde alors pourquoi ces
noms parce que c'est des chiffres du
livre on sait alors si ça marche mais
non mais c'est pas ça mbodj derrière
derrière une cheminée une série qui le
dos mais laissez moi finir arrêt permet
si le libre marché
c'est pas ça c'est que on sait très bien
pourquoi il est en train d'engranger des
sous pour quoi tout ça est télécommandé
pourquoi il ya des gens qui lui donne
des ordres à faire en cachette c'est
pour financer sa prochaine campagne
heures
il ya du bon président parce que s'il
s'est déclarée inquiète vraiment là il
engrange et avec qui c'est
le choc avec
quelqu'un mais qui ne partagent pas
visité gagne de l'argent
c'est d'ailleurs ce chantier et c'est
pas du tout ça ou de n'importe qui non
mais qu'est-ce qui le jeu hypocrisie je
ne comprends pas une hypocrisie l'époque
raid il engrange des sommes folles qu'il
m'ait bbc les excuse c'est que ces six
volets sur l'axé un succès se lancer
mais j'ai pas dit que c'était illégal je
suis choquée mais non pour ce que je
n'ai pas lancé dans une campagne
électorale
rim avait
alors 16 ans il me dit khamis d'écart
quand il veut mais moi je vous dis je
suis choquée pour ça parce que les gens
me farthouat en achetant son livre
mais les gens sont bien les gens quelle
conviction
les gens les gens qui essaient de son
lycée parce qu'ils sont en grande partie
en du claé a priori d'accord avec ses
idées dont qui les achètent c'est une
forme de contribution à son mode de
pensée voilà et puis en fait qui
claquent son argent excuse moi oui il va
servir de son agent vient pour la
terrienne tu prennes avec les mois d'été
avec cris des lits en fait il va tout
plein en saccharose aurait choqué de
prendre 2 millions d'euros allait bien
et surtout un candidat gtep avait alors
arrêté
effectivement c'est vrai parce que vous
savez tous les candidats à la
présidentielle sortent des livres non qu
il devrait sortir des luttes que trois
bombes du 30 exemplaires
s'il serait presque plus choquant c'est
lille c'est qu'il fasse froid qui va se
présenter il fasse de l'argent avec son
livre il se présente pas la nuit pour ce
matin
je suis assez d'accord il s'agit de choc
vous parce que alors vous vous êtes de
la france insoumise merci avec la voile
aperçu que c'est que ce sont des amis
julie garnier c'est la première fois que
je vous ai d'ailleurs en bonne oratrice
national sa veux dire quoi porte parole
brown voiture ça alors merci
et vous ça vous choque nous va bien sûr
que oui mais sachez-le pourquoi ses
coûts déjà parce que c'est décemment
fallait absolument la alors ça fait
personnes soit par vous et gilles verdez
non seulement il ya des revenus
indécents mais en plus il fait de
l'indemnisation fiscale et c'est ça
aussi qui est derrière est dégueulasse à
ce que alors c'est un gars c'est légal
ce qui est presque annonce à fait légal
c'est l'optimisation gp10 est [ __ ] par
des jeunes aux éditions le réveil dire
qu'ils s'arrangent pour payer le moins
mais on n'a pas le droit de faire ça
j'ai juste dit que ce monsieur là est
encore candidat à la présidentielle
également déclaré sénégal avec lui c'est
légal et qu'un d'optimisation j'ai pas
dis évasion j'ai bien fermé l'angle de
légale par contre celui qui lui fait de
l'évasion c'est celui qui le financent
notamment charles gave qui lui a fait ça
tourne sur les paraître de lawson qui
dit qu'une financement est là dessus
dans mes romans thema la taille du rar
quoi ça le met chez une amie proche des
revenus par peau au soleil fait une
timide avions donc armé
on avait le banquier macron maintenant
on essaye de nous vendre l'optimiseur
fiscale non mais ça va ça suffit les
latics vous allez me répond pas à battre
lors des prochaines émissions où tu
étais d'ailleurs moi je venais que j'ai
perdu mais je pense que toi tu devais
payer tu vois aucun rapport les
proppants d'envoyer quelque chose au
même moment mois janvier deux mois les
revenus quand vous étiez payer sur le
palier du pays comme ma chère
vous plaît c'est peu de dire que c'est
pas nous
l'opération d'hier pourrait sociaux eric
zemmour bien sûr eric zemmour juste pour
terminer quand même parce qu'on
représente quand même l'envié vous dit
vous choque parce que les profs 2
millions d'euros pour son heavy la
droite si ça marche bien mais c'est
surtout quelle époque il a pas le chargé
d affaires quand on fait de
l'optimisation fiscale céder sous
condamne pas dans les hôpitaux ces
dessous qu'on donne pas dans les écoles
dans la justice etc et quand on est
candidat à la présidentielle c'est de
pouvoir se poser les bonnes questions et
moi je pose cette question là
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui se
battent là en ce moment et d une casse
sociale terrible dans ce pays il ya des
à disney il ya des femmes de ménage me
suis enchaîné aux grilles de disneyland
paris rien que cet après-midi parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de contrat de travail
jeu ça fait sept semaines que je côté
des conducteurs contrôleurs et aux tests
de transdev va pas max os mais je serai
révise hémolytique et urémique
shu répondez non mais en fait vous et je
pense que vous êtes sûr vous êtes
tellement dans une sorte de haine
viscérale contre ces mots qu'en fait
vous ne devez pas de lgv sea un bon ben
c'est mal et vite jean luc mélenchon est
l'origine de sa fortune personnelle je
prie aussi pour laquelle des transdev
vous les données que vous donne de ses
nouvelles choses c'est l'argument alors
oui mais non est alors oui mais j'aurai
je comprends pas vous êtes en train de
dire en gros que zemmour est malhonnête
c'est ça qui fait il est malhonnête
intellectuellement on fait de
l'optimisation à la fin c'est légal il a
le droit de le faire mais l'arrêt tout
vous dit tout à fait le droit de le
faire mais il a le droit aussi de
constater aujourd'hui que notre pays est
dans une casse terrible définitive
juillet sa juste part d'impôts
aujourd'hui problème s'il ya des riches
qui paient pas leur juste part d'impôts
et c'est pour ça qu'à chaque fois on
demande à tous les gens là bas les gens
travailler jusqu'à 67 sur nos efforts
sur moi il fallait pour cent des gens
vous pensé à lui pour son équipe ce sont
des antilles ce sont des milliardaires
je dis juste posez vous les bonnes
questions la france a subi juste pour
les gens du bas vous savez pas perdre
pied vote est d'ailleurs normal on a
fait des sondages je vous assure vous
les sondages soit 50% d'abstention je
les connais je vais bien voilà c'est
quelque chose que j'ai envie de dire
posez vous les bonnes questions
aujourd'hui on est en train de saigner
les gens on est en train de les taxer
que ce soit à la pompe à essence sur
leur temps ils avaient tous
je ne suis pas maître lire ici tu les
juger
par cette histoire d'optimisation des
mêmes choses il enregistrait 2 millions
d'euros il paye ses impôts puisque
immunisation il paye pas sa juste part
d'impôts s'il est apte à un accord avec
ça alors vous n'êtes pas d'accord patrie
non ils vous oubliez un détail quand
même c'est vous faites semblant de
croire que l'optimisation fiscale il n'y
a rien derrière quand l'état vous offre
une optimisation fiscale c'est parce
qu'à un moment donné vous entrez dans un
programme bloqué pendant une durée qui
soit 7 ou 9 ans et que donc à un moment
donné il trouve son compte arrêtez
d'être naïve madame je veux dire je veux
bien vous ayez de la haine ou peu
importe du mépris comme la rosée moore
même en donner l'optimisation fiscale at
ça compte et n'importe quoi l'état y
trouve son compte c'est pour ça qu'il
n'a jamais abandonné les niches fiscales
c'est le deuxième pour qu'il y ait
l'ivresse en fait pour certains je vous
dis fiscales sont faites pour ceux qui
payent des impôts oui pardon mais si
vous aviez pas de quoi s'équiper dès
qu'ils payent des impôts aux hôpitaux d
ascq vous offrir
à terme échu au deuxième point en
réalité si vous me permettez de regard
moi j'en ai marre qu'on parle du
business moi j'ai eu droit à un article
j'ai eu beaucoup moins de lui mais je
voudrais à un article de l'express du
jdd sur le juteux business de pare brise
des vies jose confirmant donné je dirais
ce qu'on a encore le droit de gagner
légalement de l'argent dans ce pays ou
pas c'est ça la question de fond parce
que finalement moi pendant ce temps là
effectivement je gagne beaucoup plus que
les femmes de ménage ou les ouvriers de
disney c'est un fait dire c'est vrai
c'est un fait on aimerait qu'il est plus
lourd et le plus
vraiment on aimerait tous je pense que
vous écris mon dernier point sur zemmour
est ce qu'elle faisait on comprend ce
qu'elle nie julie elle dit qu'on
aimerait bien
il peut servir c'est pas moi qui
contredirait ça pour le coup je me bats
suffisamment là dessus aujourd'hui
imposition qui est injuste savait qu'on
prenait sa région
un autre débat ça c'est vous qu'on n'est
pas raisonnable
il ya d'abord excusé moi oui je le
répète quand je travaille je suis payé
aussi choquant que cela vous semble et
jeu et je compte bien moi quand j'allais
à l'heure des couches mais je ne peux
pas travailler gratuitement je vous le
dis que ça vous plaise ou pas oui je
suis payé par ses news donc et j'en suis
très contente mais la deuxième chose
c'est qu'on oublie une chose dans cet
appel 6 aimons gagner autant d'argent
c'est pourquoi et bien parce qu'il a
beaucoup de succès parce que pour le
coup contrairement à ce qui se passe
dans un certain nombre d'endroits où
vous gagnez de l'argent indépendamment
par exemple du public ou indépendamment
de vos performances et la demande donc à
dire si zemmour est employée par ses
news vous croyez que ces news est une
entreprise depuis l'entropie vous croyez
qu'ils ont payé je ne sais pas je ne
connais pas les chiffres mais vous
l'aviez 3000 2000 ou 3000 par admission
vous croyez que ça ne rapportait pas en
pub c'est tout simplement ce que vous
n'avez pas et a visiblement déjà dire
que je suis navré zemmour vend des
livres il alors je n'ai jamais vu
prendre une kalachnikov fait dire à
quelqu'un m'a tant qu acheter mon lit et
brun parce que sinon ça vous fait peur
oui donc en face qui vous des bêtes de
cesson subissait alors alors elle a
répondu à l'article de libération sur
wii c'est votre problème regardez il a
répondu c'était chez pascal garrigues
s'est dit justement où vous n'étiez pas
payer vous voilà non je n'ai pas payé
mais n'a pas l'air de choquer madame
n'est due que les gens soient pas payés
pour leur travail regarder j'aime bien
quand les les journalistes de libération
reproche à des gens de vendre des livres
et de gagner de l'argent avec la vente
des livres quand eux-mêmes vivent de nos
subventions publiques et de nos impôts
vous savez il ya les lecteurs quand il
ya très peu de lecteurs à libération
d'après le site du gouvernement j'ai
regardé en 2016 quatre millions 887
milles euros de subventions payées par
nos imprimés toute la presse toute la
presse mais libération particulièrement
parce qu'il ya du mouvement plus de
lecteurs alors
oui moi je suis choquée là il est enfin
temps sur libé c'est vrai qu'il m'est
subventionné moi j'en ai marre parce que
vous considérez que ce business il est
normal vous passez sous silence
l'optimisation fiscale c'est vrai vous
passez sous silence le fait qu' il se
prétend le défenseur des petites gens et
l'huile en main il emmagasine du pognon
du pognon et du pognon et moi je suis
choqué sur le plan moral après on peut
juger que ma position vous auriez dit
ça
le défenseur des ponts bleus défense
juste six ans et présentait pas aux
élections ça ne vous en foutez alors moi
je m'en fous si les deux ans de police
mais évidemment le business c'est du
business mais là vous comprenez pas
qu'en fait il est en train de ratisser
pour trouver des financements pour sa
campagne et comme il se
doit d'être choqué quand même fêter ce
titre agira d un grand père
gilbert jean pierre allez je vais vous
dire un truc là vous dites n'importe où
excusez moi je vous dire la vérité vous
croyez vraiment qu'eric zemmour quand il
a 17 % dans les sondages vous croyez
vraiment qu'il ya pas une banque qui va
lui prêter ses employés sérieux ça
soyons sérieux arrêtez de dire des
bêtises c'est sûr et certain qu'ils vont
lui prêter l'argent arrêté
oui mais là aucune chance de faire moins
de 5% la seule qui a des soucis en ce
moment et je le sais c'est anne hidalgo
qui arrive pas parce que forcément ils
ont peur d'une vision à long terme on
doit le faire des travaux avec ou bien
là
arrêté
jamais
en lui qu'il a aucun problème parce que
genre il y aussi on sait qu'il va faire
un score arrêté dit la vérité jean luc
mélenchon il n'y a pas de problème pour
financer sa campagne non non c'est pas
ce nom non point nettement le
financement de campagne un vrai sujet là
dessus mais moi je vous dis qu'il faut
il n'a pas besoin de vois là on avait
normalement il prévu soit disant une
banque démocrate rappeler que ça mais
y'a plus rien parce que joueuse je
rappelle au téléphone fait moins de 5%
vous n'êtes pas ailleurs monia risque
énorme et c'est une catastrophe on y
arrive vous trompez sur une chose marine
le pen ce qu est un fou et que j'allais
reprendre la vie qui a eu beaucoup de
problèmes pour ça vous paraît llodra est
ce un scandale alors qu'elle était au
delà des 5 % évidemment ouais donc
raté puisque nos candidats y compris
ceux qui sont crédités de scores
importants ont des difficultés majeures
à trouver des banques pour financer
leurs campagnes parce que les banques
ont elles mêmes des problèmes pour
trouver des assurances pour assurer la
fonction des sondages et d'ailleurs mais
prêts bancaires ce qui pousse un certain
nombre de candidats à aller et c'est le
cas d'ailleurs d'eric zemmour passage
voire des banques étrangères et de la
vue par exemple des salariés de banque
saoudienne est ce qui ne manquera pas
d'être utilisés par ses opposants
politiques comme une sorte de
contradiction comme marine le pen s'est
tourné vers l'est de l'europe pour
tenter de trouver quelqu'un qui la
finance mais on ne peut pas moi je le
crois reprocher à ces candidats de se
tourner hors de nos frontières si la
france n'est pas capable de financer sa
démocratie et ça ça pose une grave
difficulté d où il est venu sonner quand
on a quand même assez d'affaires sur les
financements de caen mène pour cela sur
des labrecque et donc sur le livre sur
le livre anne hidalgo elle a sorti un
livre nicolas sarkozy françois hollande
tout le monde sort un livre même même le
ministre de l'éducation a sorti un livre
oui quand on lui reproche de leleu de le
faire lui-même la son bouquet est fan de
le de l'auto et dire que tout le monde
oublie calme à michel l'avait lâchée en
plein emploi elle a été organisée
bref duc de tout ça m'énerve ou est dupe
de tout vous faudrait lui reprocher et
comme le dit ça va ça va bien c'est quoi
quel est le désir de gagner deux appels
elle dit n'importe quoi
vous fait gagner de l'argent c'est mal
quand on s'appelle eric zemmour c'est ça
mais ils seront plus possibles quand il
va se déclarer candidat et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela qu'ils ne se
déclare pas tout de suite il pourra plus
faire payer l'entrée à ces conférences
il adore faire du sol et la comté rural
tout cela n'aura pouvoir la france et de
la clarté nous ferons pas pu diana et
une défaite elle était si la raison d'un
front populaire payé par front populaire
il n'a pas tout changé mais il ya que
sett tv en fait partie du comité de
soutien d'eric
partie du comité de soutien d'eric
zemmour je n'aurai aucun problème aux
médias qu'il avait bâtie pour qu'il vous
que je me fous éperdument de vos
champions préférés à cyril vous allez
voter pour kim je ne sais pas marine le
pen
sinon ils sont trop à gauche
même si je savais jamais le bout je ne
vous le dirais pas parce que moi je suis
qui a parlé de l'isoloir tout à l'heure
c'est ce qu'il veut je suis assez
attachés
activement parce que nous à comprendre
si vous voulez qu'on aille chercher
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est que ça
te regarde le passé j l'apprenti secret
du vote oui qu'est ce que vous vouliez
dire non qui l'accusent il zemmour ou
zemmour le pen a aussi tapé ce qu'est le
choléra dans medal évident de le dire on
le sait ce n'est jamais méchant mais si
on n'a plus droit de van est oui dit on
à la mission un sur d'accord en face moi
il ya plusieurs
sujets d'elizabeth on va pas se mentir
je ne pense pas que vous allez voter
voulons lui planchon
hidalgo
a pas que vous allez voter pour
quelqu'un
pour quelqu'un part de roue en terminant
rien qui à part
ça dépend dans quelle circonstance
mélenchon macro à
tour